thank you so much for coming to talk
with me this afternoon I'm really
honored to be here as I told Tom I was
nervous to accept the opportunity to
speak here because I actually was here
about 20 years ago carrying the bag of
my boss former boss John doar when he
gave his ETL talk and I now know so John
told me a couple months before his Yale
talk hey like I just got invited to do
this
ETL talk it's a really big deal like the
smartest most entrepreneurial minded
people at Stanford go to ETL we have to
make sure it's really good and so I
spent two months working on his slide
presentation for his ETL and so when I
got asked to do ETL I was like there's
no way I can do that
and so I'm you know so I'm a little
nervous and my slides definitely don't
look as good as did at the time but
thanks for having me I know you have a
lot of choices probably spend your
afternoon so I'm gonna just tell you a
little bit about me and then I'm gonna
actually open it up to questions in the
beginning I'd love to make sure this is
your time your hour that we spend the
time talking about stuff that you want
to hear about so I'll just give you a
little background so maybe you have a
better idea of where I come from and
stuff that we might be able to talk
about so I'm a first generation
immigrant from my parents were both born
in China and they came here separately
in through different journeys and went
through Ellis Island and one settled in
Iowa and one settled in New York and
then they met here in the United States
and and so the immigrant story is a big
part of my upbringing my grandparents at
a Chinese restaurant in Yonkers New York
and everyone in the family is to help
out and work there so kind of that work
ethic and also understanding everything
that my grandparents and my parents went
through to make it so that I could be
standing here in front of you is just
really important part of my I think my
work ethic and my values that that lady
I couldn't find a picture of myself with
what I was brought I was born in Staten
Island New York and then I moved to New
Jersey and I could not find a picture of
what my hair look like back then but
it's that's like a close approximation
to what my hair look like back then and
I was fortunate to go to MIT as Tom
mentioned and
the reason why was I read an article I
think in time or Newsweek back this
isn't the late 80s about what they were
calling at the time scientific
illiteracy which is really about high
school kids studying STEM fields and
showing a predilection or a discomfort
with STEM fields and in particular while
girls were test and whorls and boys were
testing equally through through
elementary school and junior high school
at high school it was turning out that a
lot of girls were dropping out of math
and science and we're not pursuing
careers or majors in college and math
and science it was creating this this
scientific illiteracy gap or a gender
gap in STEM and when I read that and
this is like I couldn't even find
something I'd have to go find microfiche
to find articles from 1988
but I mean sadly it still exists right
that's an article from ninth from 2017
but that really made me mad and it made
me frustrated cuz it just didn't seem
right that girls should not be pursuing
important careers that were quantitative
and in math and science and so I decide
to fly to MIT I know that's not actually
like the normal path and I was woefully
underprepared and so it really kicked my
butt for four years but I was I'm very
grateful that they let me in and then I
got to graduate and I got to meet some
fantastic people and it turned out that
MIT helped me prepare for my future
career because it turns out that my my
professional calling is actually working
with very smart technical founders and
being a great business partner to them
and helping them kind of translate their
our technical ideas into business so
after that I went to I didn't really
know what I wanted to do when I
graduated from undergrad so I got a job
as a financial analyst at Morgan Stanley
in New York City I was in the M&A
department which was probably one of the
more quantitative analyst jobs it's
really fun really challenging and but I
felt like I probably would apply to
business school but maybe for a third
year before business school I would try
and do something different so I actually
went to that's a picture of Fudan
University what it used to look like in
the 80s and 90s it doesn't exactly look
like that anymore but I went there too
at the time Shanghai was gonna be the
next New York and it was really China
was really an emerging economy and
Shanghai was like just actually a much a
fraction of the size that it is today
and I thought maybe my career would be
being one of those people who could
speak Chinese and go back and forth and
do business in Asia and on the west
coast so I went to go brushed up on my
team
Chinese I studied Chinese in the
mornings and I taught English in the
afternoons and then I had like I had a
sweater a backpack and a bicycle and
that was pretty much it and it was
probably one of the best years of my
life when I was there I borrowed a
friend's typewriter and I wrote my
business school applications has anyone
here used a typewriter okay yes good
like 15 people and I was fortunate to
get into business school so that's where
I went to business school and when I was
at business school I always had I had
grown up working at the Short Hills Mall
in Short Hills New Jersey and different
retail jobs and I always had a real
interest in both retail and consumer
products and consumer brands and
particular brands that created a lot of
customer love and so I did internships
at the North Face and Odwalla
that were both kind of high-growth
private startups at the time when I was
in business school and then I went to go
work for a company called gap and I
don't know if you any of you is anyone
here remember a time when everyone used
to work khakis I know for a lot of young
people you'd be like what but this is
basically gap at the time like this was
the uniform that everyone wore and we
were probably like the hottest company
in retail and that's from one of our ads
it was really a fun time to work at Gap
it was like a talent magnet company
where some of the best and brightest
people in marketing and merchandising
and planning and supply chain worked I
learned a ton and along the way I had
always heard it I had heard of venture
capital when I was at Morgan Stanley and
it seemed like such a dream job getting
to work with founders hearing their
ideas trying to decide which people to
do business with and to back and then
helping them build their companies but
at the time when I was an analyst at
Morgan Stanley my understanding was
venture capital was all dudes and it
would probably not be an environment
that I would fit in or I'd feel
comfortable or that they would really
want me so I never even introduced for a
job out of Morgan Stanley and I was
really fortunate that I got a call from
a recruiter who was looking for an
associate at Kleiner Perkins and I said
you know it sounds like a really
interesting job I actually feel like I
would love it but I just don't know if
I'm comfortable going to being the only
woman at a firm like most of these firms
are all men and and the recruiter was a
woman and she said Aileen if every woman
I call says that we will never get women
to work in venture capital that really
worked on me so
and so I went in for the interview and
fortunately I actually didn't know very
much about venture capital so I wasn't
actually super intimidated by the people
and I later kind of as I did my research
I realized like in room with John Doerr
or Vinod Khosla or some of these people
was kind of like a big deal and I was
really fortunate I got the job and so
that's where I worked for 12 years where
we did you know at the time we were we
were the first investors in Amazon and
in Google and in Genentech and Netscape
and a bunch of really interesting kind
of game-changing companies and those are
the kinds of people who would kind of
walk through our halls during the day
and I got to work with incredible people
and learned a lot along the way I felt
like I didn't have enough operating
experience to really become a great like
kind of partner to founders so we had
invested in a company called den new
that was founded actually by two
Stanford grads
and and it wasn't going the way that we
hoped and they asked me to step in as
founding CEO or maybe CEO for this
summer like in retrospect that was a
very naive thought like it's really not
possible to be CEO for the summer and so
I went in it did that job for two years
planner was an investor we raised a
series B and you know so we had a great
like a great year and then the recession
hit in 2008 and we had a really tough
year and we had to lay off half the
company and then we wound up acquiring
two of our closest competitors and then
I replaced myself so I did that job for
two years while I was kind of going back
and forth with between Daniel and
kleiner and it was a really great
experience I'm grateful to have had like
that time both through good times and
really tough times running a venture
back startup and then in 2012 as Tom
mentioned I started cowboyed ventures
and I had been doing series a and B and
doing mostly consumer investing but some
enterprise software some media some
green tech at Kleiner and I decided to
move earlier to seed which was a new
category that was really had been in
place for a couple years but it really
wasn't a very established institutional
venture category but it's also more
collaborative you're starting earlier
you're investing less so we in versus
writing you know investing four or eight
million dollars in a company at seed at
the time you're investing five hundred
thousand seven hundred fifty thousand a
million dollars in companies when
they're really just getting started and
then they graduate from us to a Series A
or series series be firm and that's what
I've been doing for the past seven years
it's been a really fun kind of
entrepreneurial journey to also you can
see our logo we have a bunch of
we have a zebra we have a quail we have
a koi fish we have an elephant and so
it's our logo is all about we picked
culturally significant like good luck
animals in different cultures and then
we have an androgynous cow person that's
riding with me like the magical animal
kind of - I think send the message that
I think we're we try to be a like a
little bit different we're a little
non-traditional and what we do at cowboy
ventures is pretty personal and so it's
really been fun to be able to start that
so with that I'm going to turn it over
to all you I'd love to make sure that we
spend the rest of the time that you have
together talking about stuff that you
want to hear about so raise your hand
I'd love if you would say your name and
either ask a question or something that
you'd love to hear about and yes sir
and I would like to hear about the
challenges which you face them when you
start a good avenges starting cowboy or
starting comedy that's later but in the
Asian life after your graduation uh-huh
and this just need okay challenges along
the journey and to create an incentive
we have a cowboy t-shirt for you if you
would like one there you go you can just
throw it at him okay who else has a
question papa
this is the back I'm curious about what
some of the challenges were that you
face when you switch from an investor
rule to an operator okay okay yes
hi which means I'm curious about your
observations that you've seen and
company some teams have been able
once you know about customer love okay
yes over there cycle select let's talk
to me what how do we decide on startups
to work with okay like investment
decisions all right have it in the back
over back there yeah I was wondering if
you could tell me more about like how
you started the venture capitalist firm
how I started cowboy yeah okay starting
cowboy okay let's see
starting cowboy okay how it over there
maybe in the red shirt alright one
turning point sorry if you can't read my
writing I will read like Reeb unch the
questions my mom said I should have been
a doctor like every day so a little
right here in the red yeah thank you for
asking that question okay all raised
okay yes and the green so I worked at an
early stage startup and it is like with
diversity efforts we can only really get
people to think sort of one access of
access of diversity at a time in
interest in getting more diversity how
do we push it so that people think of it
as a more cohesive yeah a long age you
know gender ok different kinds of
diversity and how we get people to
really embrace it in over there
and I'm curious about your writing
process when you do the articles okay
riding on it okay thanks
yes over there
and you mentioned that you have no
experience but that your pet will coming
in so how did you all like to make that
experience right okay so that kind of
goes a little bit with the challenge in
the journey like getting VC like mindset
okay let's see how many I love that you
guys have so many questions so awesome
how about over there in the black
a very likes my department like I'm
gonna give these chefs public sauce
building communication skills like right
on glass - meaning important oh yes my
question is what I guess to express
advice going to build with soft skills
like how do you also like I guess one of
your team members you love yeah
developing soft skills and communication
skills okay let's just do one more and
then hopefully we'll have some time at
the end to do questions as well
okay right there in the what okay oh
that's a hard one I might have to ask my
team members who are here Amanda Meyer
to answer that but it's a really hard
one what make why should I take your
money
okay and then you want just like you can
just throw out the rest of the t-shirts
if you guys want to anyone who wants to
raise your hand if you want a t-shirt
hahaha yeah I'm glad you like them okay
I'm gonna okay all right so I'm gonna
I'm gonna bucket these kind of like
maybe like BC career and then maybe
starting cowboy and then coming in
Harris like writing and thinking and
skill development and then at the end
we'll talk a little bit about all Dre's
I'll try and bucket all of the things
that you asked about in these different
categories so and so you know my first
job at Kleiner Perkins was so when I
worked at Gap after business school and
I did a couple of different jobs and I
really I guess a couple things
especially if you're in college and you
haven't decided where you're if you're
an undergrad or grad student and you
haven't decided where you're gonna work
yet or you haven't started your job
search like at business school some of
the companies they started recruiting in
the fall so by Christmas or by the new
years a lot of my friends had jobs and
they had very high paying jobs and I
knew I wanted to work for a consumer
company or maybe a start-up or so like
that and so and at the time most of
those companies did not recruit a
business school so I basically every
lunch break I will go back to my dorm
room and I would like basically I had
looked up things at the library because
there wasn't really an internet yet but
and I would call companies and I would
just ask to talk to the vice president
of marketing or the director of
marketing or the director of product
management or the director supply chain
and I would just basically if I could
catch someone on the phone I would ask
them if they had any jobs I really
pounded the pavement for months and
launched and I found this lady named
busy Brewer who was a GSB grad working
at Gap in strategy and she took a chance
on me and she gave me a job even though
she didn't really have an open rack and
I joined her in the small consulting
group working for the president of Gap
trying to help figure out how we're
gonna grow the top line and so sometimes
that was a supply chain project
sometimes it was a pricing project
a store assortment project but I just
did kind of like an internal consulting
job and I just I loved the chance to
learn and busy was really smart so
you've probably heard the advice like
pick your boss basically I loved the
company and I really loved the person to
be working for and so I I took the job
even though the pay was so much less
than a lot of other jobs that I was
offered or that my friends were getting
is I just figured like and I to be
honest my my family had like a little
bit of an intervention with me because
they were like hey like we didn't spend
all this money to help you go to these
schools that you could go work at the
gap and like and you know retail is
really not where we envisioned that this
would be ending up and I just had a
feeling like it was a time to do
something that I would be really
passionate about rather than trying to
do something that people would like
think was a good job or admired and I
think after college you there's no
longer a ladder right and there's no
longer a path so you really have to
figure out what you're gonna be
passionate about and ideally put
yourself in a situation where you gonna
be with a lot of smart people and you'll
have the chance to learn and because I I
was in that situation I did a good job
and so in my second year that the the
CEO of gap at the time was a guy named
Mickey Drexler who's probably one of the
greatest living merchants in America or
in the world
he went after gap he did j.crew he's
just an incredible retail leader and
merchants and he had this like internal
star search to pick he had decided he
was gonna take on a chief of staff every
year and I wound up being a finalist and
we basically put like maybe eight or ten
of the finalists at a lunch table
together and he basically would just sit
like he sat there and he just peppered
us all with questions it was such an odd
process but he really wanted to know
where like where you came from and what
you cared about and what your values
were and what motivated you and I talked
a little bit about my family and I
talked a little bit about working in
retail and I talked a little bit about
caring a lot about customers and I don't
really know what it was but I got the
job so I wound up being chief of staff
to the CEO of a public company when I
was just eager out of business school
and I just worked my tail off I was
there two hours before he showed up
every day I was there for two or four
hours after he left every day and it was
like ridiculous multitasking because on
the one hand it's a public company and
you're supporting the CEO who's
got shareholders and real estate and
debt and financials and analyst reports
and store reports and international and
gap and B gap Baby Gap and Banana
Republic and all these different things
and also there's and we care a lot about
customers like we would read customer
complaints we had read letters and write
them back and like so kind of from the
high of the low it was just it was an
amazing and then also sometimes people
would like you know some famous actor or
journalist would walk in and make you
would say what's happening Dennis Hopper
right and Dennis Hopper would be like
dude Stockholm is so cool right now and
then he would just look at me and you'd
be like make it happen and then like
basically 48 hours later I would be I
would be on the phone calling all of
Mickey's friends being like what are the
cool stores we should visit what are the
right hotels one of the restaurants one
of the cool trends what street should we
go to to see people wearing street wear
and then like three three days later we
would have this junket of Gap people
going to Sweden or like going to
Stockholm to check out like the fashion
and the style and the culture and like
putting together like to dream days like
it was just like every day your would
get totally blown up and you'd be doing
crazy things and after that job I got to
kind of pick where I went in the
organisation and I picked the internet
job the internet business was the thing
that was kind of I thought the most
exciting gap kana and it was a tiny team
and so we were just really trying to it
was like I start up inside of a big
company and we just had to learn about
like what what do you do to run a site
every day like do you change the
homepage every day to keep it the same
like do you send emails do you not send
emails like just so many what do you do
with customer data like so many things
that there are no rules back then and we
just were trying to figure it out and so
I guess the that all those things
prepared me for going into venture
capital in a way because I got exposed
to a lot of different functions I did
inside the same company change jobs
pretty much every year and and the chief
of staff job actually helped me because
I went to kleiner as a chief of staff as
the one of the associates working for
John doar and just John had such a full
plate and so many different portfolio
companies and so many people wanted to
meet with him and it was really
important for us to make sure we always
showed entrepreneurs like the utmost
courtesy and professionalism and
attentiveness and then also he had a lot
of
kind of political or kind of civic cause
things that he was passionate about like
public education and improving
California schools things like that that
I'm super excited to work on and so I
just was constantly thinking about what
is important to John and what are his
priorities and also what are the parties
of the firm and I just tried to apply
myself to whatever things needed to be
done so that we could accomplish our
goals as a team and I think that
mentality I mean it's something that we
talked about at cowboy ventures that has
served me incredibly well in my career
so that whenever I got placed into a
situation where I didn't really know a
lot you know I'm trying to learn and I'm
asking questions so I can make the team
achieve its goal help the team achieve
its goals and so it has basically lots
of people were helpful to me to help me
figure out the things that I don't know
so I'm trying to think about well so the
VC mindset was in my opinion in my
experience VC was an apprenticeship
business so I didn't jump in say oh yeah
I'm ready to be a VC I kind of I took
the job and I was like I'm ready to
learn and serve and that's basically
what I did for five or six years working
for different partners first John and
then different partners at Kleiner
Perkins and trying to understand how
they work with their portfolio companies
how they help founders navigate problems
how they help them raise money or
introduce them to customers or work on
marketing programs or those kinds of
things and so I kind of learned through
apprenticeship by going to lots of lots
of meetings and spending a lot of time
with founders interviewing candidates
trying to understand like if a candidate
didn't work out why if we were part of
the interview process what should we
have asked differently so we could have
figured that out so I just did that for
many many years and that was what kind
of helped me develop my mindset as an
investor also getting to see what
happens to the companies so you have a
thesis you write a memo you do your
diligence you make the investment you
work with the founders for a number of
years and sometimes it goes well and
sometimes it doesn't and so trying to
basically piece together some heuristics
about like what do they have in common
or what are the signals that you can
tell you're out of work in the road and
that you need to help the founders
understand that they're at an important
fork in the road and that the decision
that they're going to me
could basically send their company in
this direction on this direction along
the way I did start writing a little bit
the one of the first things I wrote was
I think a blog post on TechCrunch called
why women roll the internet and it was
just about how I think women are the
unsung heroes of a lot of companies
where there are the majority customers
for most internet companies most
e-commerce companies whether it's travel
whether it's social media even whether
it's casual gaming but most of the
companies were founded by men and most
of the companies didn't have a lot of
women working at the companies and it
was the idea that I think we we had an
opportunity to both embed more of the
customer into these companies because
companies might inadvertently be making
decisions that actually the customer
can't relate to because it's a bunch of
guys sitting around a table trying to
guess like how the customer who's
generally often a woman would use the
product and it was hard for me to write
I was I'm like a very slow writer and
I'm a nervous Rider so I write and then
I leave it and then I wonder like is
that dumb is anyone gonna think it's
done and then I go back to it a couple
days later or maybe a week later and I
like work on it a little bit and then so
unlike some investors or you know
obviously journalists who can kind of
like just come out with stuff every day
or every couple days I definitely
definitely more of a once a quarter a
couple times a year
writer but I I tried to write things
that are both in my head but also maybe
a point of view that I feel like hasn't
been expressed or like an insight that
that hasn't been shared yet so over over
the weekend I posted something called
nobody is batting a thousand I don't
know if anyone has seen that or not but
it's basically this idea that maybe at a
place like Stanford or in the startup
ecosystem you hear things like they're
crushing at or they're killing it or oh
my god we were super oversubscribed and
like it can make you feel bad about
yourself right or like I got ten offers
or you know like oh my god you know how
much he is making or she's making and it
could make you feel insecure or like you
have imposter syndrome and one of our
daughters play softball
sometimes she has a really good she's a
good hitter but sometimes she doesn't
hit the way she wants to and like once
you've hit a homerun or you've hit a
triple if you don't hit a home run in a
triple in the next game you feel bad
like you feel like you're a bad player
and I've seen players decide that like
think about quitting because they
couldn't keep up with the thing that
they have in their head about like how
they should be hitting and the thing I
my daughter and I talked about is
batting average alright like does anyone
here know what the best batting average
in history is in baseball or softball
what is it yeah it's basically around
like batting average is like every when
you're at the plate and you get like the
ball in a game gets pitched to you what
percent of time do you actually hit the
ball to get into play so you get on base
either first second third or home
basically in baseball the most that the
best baseball player has ever done is
thirty percent of time get on base right
so 70 put on the time the best players
in history have not gotten on base and
so it's the idea that not to get sucked
into this feeling like everyone is
crushing it and that if you're swinging
and you keep playing and you're being
thoughtful about your swing and your
preparation and you're doing the work
you just kind of stay in the game and
you got to keep swinging and don't ever
think that everyone's batting a thousand
because they're not how are you doing on
time ok ok so I'll move to starting
cowboy ventures so in 2012 I started a
seed fund called cowboy ventures kleiner
perkins had grown pretty big over the
years that I had been there for 12 years
and we had different practices and it
and I was a senior partner at the firm
so all the senior partners were getting
pulled into a lot of internal meetings
just to try and make sure that we were
making good decisions for the venture
practice for the growth practice for the
green tech practice for the life
sciences practice for China for things
we were doing in India a lot and then
and the venture environment was changing
where this new category of seed was was
starting and a few of us at Kleiner were
advocating that we should be doing some
seeds but we had a very big fun we had a
very big team it's kind of sometimes
it's hard to justify making small
investments when you're a big fun
and so uh my husband and I were at
dinner with a couple that are both
entrepreneurs and one of them knew
kleiner very well and she asked me how
how things were going and I was like
well you know it's sometimes it's hard
to navigate who's gotten bigger and she
and he both said when are you gonna
leave and start your own firm and I have
to admit even though I had been working
with founders for 20 years and working
with entrepreneurship 20 years and not
crossed my mind she start my own firm
and I think some of it was like really
you guys think I could start my own firm
and and they're like yes we definitely
think you could start your own firm and
I think this is actually apparently very
consistent with research on gender
differences that a lot of times women
have to be like told that they shouldn't
run for like men you know if someone's
running for office he's like oh yeah
where do I sign up right but a lot of
women
the studies show have to be told you
should do this and they do a great job
when they do it but and I'm sure a lot
of it is because of how we're brought up
and and what how society does treat
different genders differently as they're
growing up and so so I went back home
and I talked to my husband and I was
like do you really think I could do that
and he said yes you should totally
should think about it you should try it
and so I spent three months working on
basically a deck describing what we
would do at cowboy ventures and how we
might be different and the things that I
wrote about how we would be different
well one is I actually am a woman and
that's just different in venture capital
sadly by definition then you are
definitely like you know you bring a
different perspectives to the table that
I had offering experience both as a
venture back founder and also and kind
of in corporate America I also have a
like some marketing and consumer
experience which is also a little bit
different and that I think over the
years because I had been in venture and
as a series a and Series B investor for
so for 12 years before starting cowboy
I've just gotten to know a ton of people
in the venture ecosystem and I've also
helped and work with a lot of companies
that have scaled past seed and so the
ability to actually work with seed
companies and be able to work with the
founders and explain to them how is the
series a investor gonna think about this
company how is a series B invest are
gonna think about this company how does
a series CMAs are gonna think about this
company and being able to coach the
founders both first helping to scale
themselves
their teams but also making sure that
they can survive and don't run out of
money is pretty unique because there are
not a lot of people who have been
traditional venture investors who moved
into seed I think like personality-wise
at cowboy ventures were a small shop
we're not like a giant firm with lots of
people
two of my awesome colleagues Amanda and
Gemma are here today and then my partner
Ted is not here today but we're we're a
small shop so when you work with cowboy
ventures you really just get us so it's
really about personal relationships and
personal chemistry and that we we are
risk takers and we half the time when we
make a seed investment there is no
product it's a founder with ideas maybe
slides but they haven't shipped it they
need the money to actually build it and
so that takes a considerable amount of
like gut and taking a leap on people and
I think that's pretty unique versus like
being very metrics driven and making
sure that like every all the numbers
pencil out during an investment ok I do
actually have some other slides so I'm
going to quickly talk about finding your
inner dolphin which is the title of this
talk so there were times and actually I
think someone asked about the turning
point your career so there were times
when I felt like I could not stand
venture and I was fortunate to do a
program at the Aspen Institute called
the crown Fellows Program where you get
put with 20 other people and you get to
read cool stuff like Maya Angelou and
MLK and and then you talk about them and
how it impacts your thinking about your
life and how your impact on society and
you do this check-in process where you
everyone goes around the circle and
talks about how they're doing and so
it's a safe space where you really get
to know the people and you get to trust
the people and I was to be honest
younger and less experienced than a lot
of the people in the room I'd always
felt like wow I can't believe I'm here
these people are so amazing and I
checked in and I said you know sometimes
I don't know if I fit in in venture
capital because I I feel like I swim
with a lot of sharks and I feel like a
guppy and I cried
and I just said like I really love this
job but I just don't know if I'm cut out
for it and my classmates they listened
and they made me feel safe and they said
you have to come up with a different
visualization for how you're feeling
like you may be swimming with sharks but
you are not a shark and you're never
gonna be a shark but you had cannot beat
yourself as a guppy because that's not
going to help maybe think of yourself as
a dolphin like adult dolphins are smart
and they swim in pods and they swim with
the sharks and they have every right to
be in the ocean but and they just swim
differently and you have to just think
of yourself as a dolphin not a guppy and
that was really helpful for me because I
for something at for some reason it
helped me visualize the like the idea
that I could stay in venture and I
didn't have to be a vest wearing bro to
keep doing my job that I could just be
myself and be comfortable with it and I
don't know if that resonates with anyone
here if you either in the past or in the
future you may find yourself in a
situation where you're really wondering
am I in the right place am i doing the
right thing and I think having the
chance to actually reflect on kind of
who you are and whether you can like be
yourself and in the environment I think
is I'm really grateful for for that
feedback that I got and then I'll talk a
little bit about following your gut
which I think hopefully speaks a little
bit to starting cowboy all raise VC
judgement so I talked a little bit about
starting cowboy and I guess in
retrospect that was a leap to leave I
was very safe and well compensated at my
former employer and so taking a leave to
start cowboy ventures it just felt like
if I wasn't gonna start something that
was smaller and more personal at that
time I would never do it and so I I took
the leap to do that the same thing about
writing the unicorn piece so when I
after I had started cowboy I had a 40
million dollar fund and no investments
and I was talking I wanted to try and
make the best investments possible out
of the fun that I had raised and I went
and talked to lots of smart investors
many of whom who speak spoken in this
room and smart LP is the investors in
our funds about like you know tell me
about some of the best funds in history
what were the company's was it one
company or three companies or five
companies and the fund that made the
breakout and what did those companies
have in common and everything was
anecdotal and there was surprisingly no
data back then in 2012 and 2013 there
was no pitchbook there was no crunch
base there was no CB insights there was
no the information and so there was like
you know billions of dollars invested by
VC firms every year and no analysis and
so I started basically making a
spreadsheet and I started making a list
of companies that were less than 10
years old that had been become worth
more than a billion dollars either in
the public or private markets and just
collecting basically information about
how many founders were there one where
the founders born and how old were they
when they founded the company where did
they go to college what did they do
before school before starting the
company where did they work how did they
know each other what was the original
idea how much money did they raise all
these different things and so I
basically created a data set of 39
companies that had been born within the
past 10 years that were worth over a
billion dollars and they actually had
quite a few things in common one of the
things at the time was when I was taking
pitch meetings from founders sometimes
founders would walk in the door and
they'd be like hey so we started this
company and I know look I'm really old
to have started this company because I'm
35 I'm sorry
and I didn't want those people to when
you did look at the analysis the
companies in the unicorn dataset were
founded by people in their 30s and 40s
they were not founded by 20 year old
dropouts from Harvard but at the time
there was like this feeling among the
entrepreneurial community that if you
haven't started your company by the time
you like by the time you finished
college you're not gonna make it and the
other thing was teams that co-founding
teams generally were the the vast
majority of the data set because it's
hard to be a solo founder and so I think
they were there a bunch of insights that
I found from the data set that I
basically wrote up in this blog post
called welcome to the unicorn Club
and the unicorn word was one that I I
didn't have that until the end so I
basically had this very long phrase that
was billion-dollar companies founded
well that's ten years that were like
they were either public or private and
venture backed and you can't really
write that many times in an essay it's
not very readable and so I had like I
did this find a replace and I was like I
was substituting like monster head or
like Godzilla or like home run and I
would reread the piece with the
different phrases and I put in unicorn
because I wanted something that was like
more fun and more mystical and made it
seem more magical and more elusive and
like and you know more special not kind
of like business analyses analysis II
and and uniform just made the whole
thing much easier to read and so that's
what I that's what I posted and so
that's kind of and I honestly did not
expect anyone to read it so it's it's
quite overwhelming but it's still a
thing actually and I guess the last
thing I'll talk about is all rays so we
talked about it a little bit you know my
20 years in venture capital for the most
of it until probably the last two or
three years I have generally been the
only woman in the room all the time and
also I mean I don't I'm not really a
person of color but in terms of under
herbs and minorities in tech or in
venture but generally also the only
non-white person in the room often often
times and tech is just such an
incredible entrepreneurship and venture
capital and tech are such an incredible
engine of innovation and growth and job
creation and economic power that it just
seems so crazy to me and also we've also
put ourselves on this this meritocracy
pedestal which we have not been and so
it just seems crazy to me that we are
not giving we're not recognizing the
inherent bias in our system and that
we're not trying to figure out how to
change it so that we create more
opportunity for people from different
backgrounds in the venture ecosystem and
then 2017 you know the news about binary
capital came out and different CEOs
behaving very badly so there was just
and Susan Fowler wrote her awesome blog
post and it was just enough
evidence that you could no longer think
that we did not have a problem in tech
and so I drafted an email to some women
friends in venture capital and I let it
sit in my draft folder for probably two
months should I stick my neck out and
try and get people together and trying
to figure out we can do text to fix this
solution or should I just try and make
cowboy ventures be successful because by
making cowboy ventures successful I will
be showing the world that being it like
hopefully up like more human person and
being a little bit different and
practicing a personal more may be very
honest straightforward style adventure
couple if we can make a lot of money and
deliver fantastic returns that will
hopefully make a difference in how
founders get treated when they work with
us and a bunch of other things but I
wound up pushing send on the summer of
2017 saying hey I'm guessing a lot of us
are feeling the same thing we're
basically the lack of women and other
folks in the venture ecosystem is just
not okay and we have a window to do
something about it
do you want to get together and talk
about things that we could do together
to make it better and bless their hearts
basically the woman on that email thread
generally all responded within an hour
to and they were like I'm in my friend
Jess Lee at Sequoia was like I'm in what
do I need to do
I'll be your flack II and like Porter
lunch you know like you know first
female partner at Sequoia was like I
will do anything I'm in and so we got
together we had a Google Doc beforehand
where we all basically wrote kind of
what are systemic issues and what are
what are root causes and what are
symptoms and what are things that we
could actually do together we have
probably 15 pages of basically notes
with each other before we got together
for dinner we had a three-hour dinner
and brainstormed okay we were all going
to get together and do something to try
and change the trajectory which is
basically just there's no trajectory and
no momentum of change in venture capital
how would we do it and we didn't realize
it at the time but we were starting
always and it has been I mean starting
cowboy and starting helping start all
raised as a collection of people has
been one of the highlights
of my personal professional career
working side-by-side with these women
and now men to try and make the venture
capital ecosystem more equitable for
more kinds of people it's just there's
so many people who care about this and
want to make it better and teaming up to
actually try and do things and help
others it has just been awesome so I
will I will close and then maybe we have
a couple minutes for questions on I'm
very fortunate to be here thank you for
having me a lot of people took chances
on me along the way
you know MIT like changed my life by
letting me in
same thing with Business School busy
burette gap gave me my first job Mickey
and John Doerr gave me jobs the women
who I emailed about the the conversation
wrote me back so many people have done
big things and small things for me to
enable me to be here today with you I
just feel incredibly grateful and also
incredibly motivated to try and make
things better for others I have a lot of
privilege and I hope to use it to its
best positive impact but everyone in
this room has a lot of privilege as well
and by being a Stanford student or being
by a member of this community by you
know where you decide to go work and
lend your talents by when you become if
you are a hiring manager or a team
member how you treat others there are
lots of like you know how you treat
people that you pass on the street or
just met like from high to low there's
lots of ways in which we have privilege
that we can use it for good and so if
you get anything from this talk I hope
you will walk out thinking a little bit
about your privilege and how you're
going to use it wisely thanks for having
me
[Applause]